this episode is brought to you by never
surrender a Galaxy Quest documentary
learn more at fandom not link / never
surrender
[Music]
it's a wonderful life prove that
everyone has value home alone showed us
why we shouldn't take family for granted
but one holiday bill will teach us
Christmas turns everyone into Anatole
jingle all the way
are you ready for a Schwarzenegger
Carboni don't worry it has just as much
violence as his other stuff he'll play
Howard leg stood near ordinary Austrian
bodybuilder mattress kingpin you're my
number one customer human amber one
customer you're my number one customer
when his neglected son what's a special
toy for Christmas Howard will plays a
one-man trail construction to buy his
kids love by any means necessary
whether that means lied to his wife's
face I got the Tillerman doll grabbing a
child by the face or punching an animal
in the face you started it
it's a music change it's of what that's
away from being a heart or slaughterfest
nothing but a harmless Christmas watch a
mad dash to find a limited release toy
in a world without smartphones or eBay
where you were constantly forced to
interact with
whoo-hoo-ho other people like the only
other global star on our knees level in
96 Sinbad
he'll play the rival sociopath Myron an
alcoholic mailman who with so many
assaults kidnapping some felonies by the
end of this thing you just know it'll be
his last Christmas as a free man Merry
Christmas
Wow sorry kid that's going to the
evidence Locker maybe one of the cops
says his son who hates him too are there
any redeeming characters in this movie
no his wife is a nagging cliche where
are you got any idea what time it is
please tell me that you did not forget
that dog you can't be going to the
office
damn you Howard the neighbor Phil
Hartman bless his soul is plowing his
way through every mom in the
neighborhood and Santa said is a lie
just a bunch of ex-cons running bootleg
toys out of a warehouse you even want to
punch Chris Parnell in the face and you
like Chris Parnell so enjoy a Christmas
film that has so little love for the
holiday it comes after the credits that
one can only hope as a satire of
commercialism because it spends 80
minutes of showing you the dark
malevolent forces of capitalism turning
us into beasts and exactly one minute
reminding us that family was the true
gift all along huh maybe they expand on
this in the sequel kill it kill it with
fire starring the goggles they do
nothing
Sinbad in this movie hi I'm Phil Arden
you may remember me from such films as
sergeant bilko loaded weapon one and
Amazon women on the moon The Phantom
Menace ok booster Howard Howard Howard
Howard Howard Howard power powered even
worse Anna and modern fandom
last action figure I'm so glad that you
make Iron Man in the 90s thanks for
watching by grabthar's hammer click the
box in the left
to learn more about never surrender I
have spoken okay boomer they call me
Cuban Pete I'm the king of the Rumba
beat when I play the maracas I go cheap
Chicka Boom Chicka Chicka Boom